- [Instructor] What I'd
like to do in this video
is explore the core
spiritual ideas of Buddhism.
And we're going to do it relative to
the core spiritual ideas of Hinduism
as described in the Upanishads.
One, because there are
significant parallels
and also because Buddha and Buddhism
grew out of a Hindu tradition.
So in both belief systems,
there's this notion
that the reality that we
are in is a quasi illusion.
In the Upanishads it's described as Maya.
That there's a true self.
That there's this atman,
which is of the same substance
as the true nature of reality, of Brahman.
That all things are actually connected.
This notion of the individual
is just an illusion
and it's illusion given
to us by this Maya.
And the Maya isn't just
our sensory perception,
it's even our notions of ego
and possibly even
time-space and causality.
In Buddhism, there is a parallel notion.
That all of what we consider to be reality
is just happening in our mind.
There isn't anything more real than that.
And we are subject to this reality
because of our constant craving
for that which is impermanent.
This craving is called Trishna,
which is the Sanskrit word,
or Tanha, which is the Pali
word, the language of Buddha.
Now because of this craving,
it leads to this constant suffering,
this Dhukka, which is really this reality
that we are subjecting ourselves to.
Now in either case, we take action
and that action leads to consequences.
And so in both traditions,
we have this notion of Karma.
And that the Karma, the
actions with consequences,
lead to further actions and consequences,
not just in this life,
but in future realities,
in whatever next Maya or reality
or life that we take on.
And this constant cycle
of birth and rebirth
is referred to as Samsara
in both of the traditions.
So you see this commonality.
Now, in Hinduism there's this idea
of trying to escape from
Samsara through meditation,
by being able to see through the Maya
and merge your atman with
Brahman, seeing that all are one.
In Buddhism, there is a similar idea.
Through meditation, through
following the eightfold path,
by recognizing the Four Noble Truths
you should escape from this
craving of impermanent things.
And in either tradition as you do that,
you escape from the Samsara.
And when you escape from the Samsara
and this cycle of Karma
leading to more and more
and the Maya and the Dhukka disappear,
in Hinduism the term is Moksha,
you have freed yourself from this cycle.
In Buddhism, the Sanskrit
word is actually Nirvana,
which literally means blown out,
but it's merging with the emptiness.
So even though officially,
a Hindu might say,
through the Moksha your atman is merging
with the ultimate reality of Brahman,
while in Buddhism, when
you achieve Nirvana,
you have recognized your nonself
and it has merged with the emptiness,
with the non-being.
Now there is debate.
Is Buddhism saying that
you should try to achieve
a state of non-existence?
Many people would disagree.
They would say Nirvana is
actually the ultimate bliss,
to recognize your nonself.
Some would say, hey this is just a matter
of what words you use.
In either case, you are recognizing
that there isn't the individual,
that you are merging
with the true reality.
That you are merging with the universe,
whether you consider the
universe to be Brahman
or whether you consider the
universe to be emptiness.
But in either tradition,
this is viewed as a state of release,
as a state of ultimate bliss
and something that you should try
to get to through practice.